hello and welcome to this video playing
members 2007 2007 okay and you so I'm
going to play the Spanish you can but
it's mentioned in a previous video I
don't feel I'm doing this right Ian ok
so I really have to look at this okay
you have a clear idea what I what I want
to do it I want to play with f5 but if
they keep the tension I'm really not
sure what the correct way of playing is
in this case I wonder if I actually take
check online the Queen trade here to be
three I can go see Marcy five looks that
looks very loose or c6 jam I know b6
looks a little bit starchy button ok now
this is ok I think it will take taking a
while to really break through now on the
on the queenside
hmm and normally you don't want to play
f4 in this kind of position but I wonder
here I mean he this is really very slow
white set up i mean is very slow okay so
he's got a five but let's see I think 96
night h4s what I want to do putting more
pressure on f3 often you don't want the
light squared Bishop traded in such a
king's indian setup but here I'm not
entirely sure because i already have g4
in so it's not like I need I needed the
light squared Bishop to to get something
going in the first place I already have
something going 95 next it's going to be
he's not even threatening to take maybe
a six but okay first of all I'm
threatening one f3 this is something
that he that he has to somehow reactor I
think
now have three is a huge threat and that
looks very difficult for why to defend
yeah this I can still play a three
Bishop takes takes on you to come on
let's not waste time going to play that
anyway at the end and now i'll check
when g5 Hanks but if i take g2 i can
take f1 Knight f3 check and so on yeah
so take everyone and then Knight f3
check or maybe maybe I have something
more directly like rook takes and then
check but this this is this is okay
check there are multiple threats screen
g4 F to check and so on when she finds
the the first one ok so here I can take
on a five maybe yeah at least he cannot
take on a five now because of Quincy
form ok Jack thought that's just just
made we move the king I have checked
here promoting United resounding test of
true yeah this is the this is how this
looks if everything goes fine
[Music]
Jim so I don't know about jacket I feel
I'm okay queen bee three yeah this is
this year this structure in itself is
not dead brilliant for black actually
because white will get in before in a
five but here with his piece placement
it takes a long time and in the meantime
I am pretty quick there this is even
this is very very slow you wanted to
play with f3 when it's just you know
this is really going very quickly look
and then I mean I'm already just around
the corner for the attack and he still I
could have taken a for you actually
right okay this is a very strong check
that's so good so forget to switch that
on it's very strong probably winning
already- for 1.4 and that that is simply
too much Queen takes was also good check
check and Jake's i think i think i play
it okay maybe there were alternatives
but blacks position is just too
overwhelming him this is how it can can
happen if white plays d5 and does not
really follow up very aggressively one
problem is you you really don't want to
do this normally you want to play in a
way that you put the pieces like that
that is quicker on the green side
potentially for c5 and the night is not
obstructing oops sorry the night is not
obstructing this bishop in the game that
was extremely slow and now we had to
move all kinds of things the rook here
look look into this night and so on it
takes ages until before is even
reisen and I'm just too quick that it
doesn't really matter that my light
squared Bishop is missing because just
um it's about time and I'm just quicker
him ok guys thanks for watching